A lot of food goes stale
or rotten when it's exposed
to air or moisture.
What happens if they stay
in a vacuum chamber
where it doesn't have either one?
[Captions by Y Translator]
YouTube user Grant Feltz asked
if food would get stale
in a vacuum chamber?
Grant that is a great question
and we would love
to try that out.
So today, we've got a variety
of foods that go bad
when they're left out.
We've got some jars that we're going
to try and turn into small vacuum chambers
with the food in them
and see what happens
to that food after a couple of weeks.
Here's what we're going to try.
We'll modify these jars so
they can hold a vacuum
with the food inside.
We'll have some food
in the vacuumed jars as well
as keeping some food
out of the jars as a control.
After two weeks,
we'll see what's happened.
We've got five different foods
that were going to test,
so let's take a look at them.
First we have a couple of apples.
We'll cut these into slices.
One bunch of apple slices will go
into a jar with all the air sucked out,
and the other batch of apple
slices will still go in a jar
but we'll leave the lid off.
Hopefully we can keep too
many fruit flies from finding it.
We may end up putting
a thin cloth barrier
just to keep them out.
We've got some milk
with an expiration date
of less than two weeks from now,
and we're going to put some
of it in the jar in a vacuum,
and some of it just leaving in the bottle,
and let it sit for two weeks
and see what happens.
Graham crackers are something that I think
get very noticeably stale pretty quickly.
If they're fresh,
they break fairly easily,
they're pretty crumbly and they
have a nice dry crunch to them.
Normally if you leave them out,
they get really soft, almost mushy.
You can't even really snap them.
They almost bend.
So we're going to try
some graham crackers in a jar.
And some graham crackers
just sitting on a plate.
Potato chips, famous for coming
in bags full of air will also go stale
if you leave them out.
Now a lot of potato chip bags
actually come full of nitrogen
rather than normal air.
And that's because the nitrogen
doesn't react as much
with the chips inside,
and we're going to give a comparison
between storing chips
with nothing, not even nitrogen,
and just leaving the bag open.
These aren't stale yet.
Delicious!
Lay's that will be 1 million dollars.
Lays?
Lays? Dang it.
And finally we have some white bread.
Bread if you leave it out,
it usually just gets really really dry
at least in this climate.
We're going to see
if the same thing happens
in a vacuum chamber.
We've got all our food laid out.
So it's time to start
making our vacuum jars.
And we've done something
similar to this before.
We took some glass soda bottles,
drilled a small hole in the cap
and had a piece of rubber
that sat over that hole.
We put the whole thing
inside our larger vacuum chamber.
And the air is able to be get sucked out
of the jar when we put pressure back in,
that rubber seal gets pressed up
against the hole,
keeping it nice and closed.
So that's what we're
going to try doing.
We've got some of these larger jars
so we can fit a good amount of food in it.
Let's see how it works.
Now we're using some electrical tape
to hold this rubber in place.
We're not trying
to hold it down.
We just want it
to not go anywhere.
So I'm not stretching
the tape tight.
I'm not pressing it down
over the whole thing.
We still want air
to be able to escape out
past this rubber and then
have it kind of sucked down on
ones there's low pressure in the jar.
Let's give this a test.
Beautiful.
We let the air back
into the main jar,
but the rubber stopper prevented it
from filling the little jar.
Now I think if we peel this
stopper away, we'll hear the air
and watch the marshmallows collapse a little.
Or a lot.
Yeah.
Yeah I'd say that's
working pretty well.
Wonderful.
All right we can fit whole
graham crackers into this jar.
So I'm just going to throw
a couple in there.
Whole slice of bread does not fit in
but I'll just cut it in half.
And I think what'll be
the best test is
I'm just going to put half
of it into the jar
and leave half of it in the other bottle.
That way there is
some air in the bottle.
A good side by side.
Don't expect graham crackers are going
to do a whole lot in a vacuum.
That already has
moisture in it.
The sides of that have started fogging up
and I'm pretty sure that is moisture
leaving the bread.
Look at all that moisture cleared up too.
Ooh. It is boiling.
The juice seems to be getting
pulled right out of our apples.
It's kind of hard to keep
them in zero pressure
and keep all the juice in place.
So, the results on the apples
may be a little strange.
I think in the spirit of making
everything as equal as possible,
trying to eliminate variables we'll just
store the non vacuumed versions in jars,
but with the lids off.
Why it was pressurized?
Why are they all pressurized?
With the apples,
I am going to put a piece
of paper towel over the top.
Maybe even tried poking
some holes in it.
I want there to be good air exchange,
but I also don't want to fill the house
with fruit flies.
Now we're going to set these
aside for two weeks
and see what has changed.
The milk will be in the fridge.
Both of them.
Everything else will
just be sitting out.
Time has now passed
and in fact more time
than we originally planned.
We were going to go
for two weeks.
And then we just got busy
with our schedule
filming other videos.
So it's actually been four weeks
that we've let these things sit out.
Which is plenty of time
for stuff to go bad.
Let's see how things are.
We're going to start
by just popping all of the seals
and we'll see it's possible that
we haven't kept a perfect vacuum
on all of these.
But we'll see how
much air seems to rush in
as we break the seals on them.
Side-by-side test.
Graham cracker sitting open
in a jar for about a month.
It does have a little bit
of snap left to it.
Not much.
And it definitely tastes
like an old graham cracker
that's quite stale.
Don't really think of graham crackers is
something that started tasting bad
but that was really not pleasant.
Much more crumbly as it snaps.
Much crisper.
And a lot more crunchy.
You can actually hear
that when I squish it
and makes like crunching sounds
and this one just kind of mushes.
This one snaps apart in the crumbs.
So graham crackers
worked really well.
Now the bread I already know
I'm not going to do taste tests
because there's mold on both of them.
However, the mold
on the open one, very minor.
There's just a little bit
growing around the edges.
The biggest difference of course
is that this is basically croutons.
The bread in our vacuum chamber.
While moldy and not really
fit for consumption,
is still completely squishy.
Like there has been no loss
of any of the moisture.
Not going to eat it
because of that.
I'm also not going
to eat this one,
and that's not because of the mold so much
as it is because this is no longer bread
fit for human consumption.
And this smells bad.
That's going back in the jar.
Potato chips sitting open in a jar.
They're so stale.
Vacuum chamber chips.
Taste like you just opened the bag.
I don't know if I can really show
the breakages different with a stale chip.
I mean they both break but that one
is softer and taste bad.
That one is much crispier
and taste delicious.
Apples, right away you can see
that things have transpired
with the apples.
The ones in this container
have obviously lost
a lot of moisture.
There is some mold forming.
The peels have become all shriveled,
the apple in general has just
become shriveled.
It's dehydrated a fair amount
and there is some mold growing
on all parts of it.
Obviously not something that
we're going to eat.
Our vacuum chambered apples don't look
like they've really lost much moisture.
Maybe a little bit, we saw some
of it even getting sucked
out of the apple when we put it
in a vacuum in the first place.
The other biggest difference is
that these have a lot more mold on them
and I think that's probably
because they still have
all of their moisture.
The dried out apples,
don't get as moldy.
The apples that just sit cut open
but have a lot of moisture in them.
Mold central.
Now we have milk.
This jar has been sitting
open in the refrigerator.
You can see that the level
of the milk has dropped.
It's dehydrated that much whereas,
this one I don't think that's changed
its in the same spot that it was before.
There's like lines on the walls
but that's from when I carried it
to the fridge and it just
swirls a little bit.
So first test.
That doesn't smell nearly as
much as I thought it would.
This is well expired milk at this point
and a lot of the time when milk goes bad,
it smells terrible.
You can smell it easily
and from a distance.
But this,
really doesn't have a smell.
Unfortunately, I am not brave
enough to try drinking that.
You can see a little bit of stuff
has formed on the surface.
I don't know how to describe it
better than that.
I think that's probably
some kind of mold.
Maybe that's just the formation
of the the milk solids.
How it happened to form up.
All right.
So this,
actually has more smell
and it doesn't smell rotten.
It just smells like milk.
I'm going to try mixing
this up a little bit.
All right.
Trying and be brave here.
It's not still good.
Like it has a little bit
of that butter milk taste
if you've ever tasted buttermilk.
It's maybe getting
just a little bit sour.
If you've ever just
had milk that's gone bad
like you accidentally poured a cup of it
or in your cereal like it's disgusting.
You want to spit it out
and maybe go vomit right away.
It doesn't taste like that.
But I'm impressed at how
well it preserved this one.
That is about three weeks
past expiration now.
Grant Feltz what you asked
is if food will get stale
in a vacuum chamber
and I think that we have demonstrated
that in terms of just going stale,
a vacuum does a really good job.
Our graham crackers and our potato
chips taste like they're completely new,
they haven't gone bad at all,
and I think that this is
a decent way to preserve them.
I don't know that it's any better
than just keeping them
in a sealed Ziploc bag
or something like that,
but this did work.
The bread did not go stale.
It did keep that from happening
but it did not prevent it from rotting.
This has mold all over it
and is definitely not edible.
Same thing with the apple.
It didn't dry out
but it did go bad.
It's moldy and you
can't eat that.
The milk, I think it probably
preserved it somewhat.
It didn't go bad as much
as this one which I admit
I'm not willing to taste because yuck.
But it's still not good.
So, keeping it
from going stale.
Yes it does.
Keeping it from going bad
in all situations,
no it definitely does not.
Grant thank you for your great idea
of something scientific we could try out
using our vacuum chamber.
If you check your YouTube inbox,
we're going to be sending you 25 bucks.
And guys remember,
if you've got a good idea,
let us know down in the comments
and if we use it to make a video,
we will send you $25.
Guys that's not all.
We've always got more
for you see.
That box up at the top
will transfer you directly
to our last video.
You should go
check that one out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And if you're not a subscriber,
just hit this bomb to get in the club
and that way you never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.